a movie where Matt Damon becomes a
cyborg then goes to infiltrate the
Citadel and mass effect yet let's let's
watch that like right now Elysium so
Elysium is written and directed by Neill
Blomkamp the director of district 9 and
future Earth in this movies pretty much
future earth and most movies except Back
to the Future 2 it's overpopulated it's
polluted it's pretty much a so
all the really rich people on earth
built this space habitat pretty much I
hate it when people over compare things
and sci-fi movies to Mass Effect's
because not all things sci-fi are Mass
Effect it's just a fact but I really do
mean it when I say this thing that all
the rich people from Earth are living on
in Elysium is the Citadel from Mass
Effect or a halo in the Halo games it's
a whole colony and they all live there
and if they're it's awesome it's like a
Garden of Eden in space everything's
great everything's all shiny they listen
to classical music to sip their brandy
they have great medical you can get your
nuts blown off and then lay down in this
bed this computer will go off Fifth
Element rebuild your balls and you're
like all right good to go it's pretty
awesome up there in Elysium down on
earth it's a tank and then for good
reasons in the movie which I like that
this movie gave us a good reason for it
matt dam is like i'm going to invade
Elysium now we have our movie
surprisingly most of the movie doesn't
take place on Elysium it's down here on
earth and more surprisingly that didn't
bother me I mean talking about Matt
Damon getting cybernetic implants and
invading Elysium it sounds more sci-fi
action movie than it is a sci-fi movie
yes it is no doubt action movie not
really the cool thing about Neill
Blomkamp movies all two of them say he
incorporates social dynamics and we'll
say social issues that we see in our
world and puts them in his movies that's
half the interesting stuff right there
it's just cool to see this world the
world is really engrossing this movies
just sucking you into the world you know
you feel it you feel it feels like it's
a real thing because it's just an
exaggeration of what we already have on
earth and the people in this movie did a
good job Matt Damon's a badass dude was
Jason Bourne so we know that he can be
an action star although I just said this
isn't really an action movie as much but
it does have action in it wasn't that
the guy's a good acting you have Jodie
Foster she's more or less running
Elysium she was good but you feel like
any middle-aged actress who's a good
actress could get a really short haircut
act like a and be like okay you're
pulling it off - turns out Jodie Foster
does it well also we're gonna talk about
this here because this dude steals the
show
Charlotte Oh Coakley the guy from
district 9
and he plays the villain in this movie
he is the mercenary that's going after
Matt Damon and company imagine the
Terminator who had a few Liars loose in
his heads it was kind of crazy that's
him in this movie and this dude is
menacing he's awesome he's cold he just
he is uncomfortable he steals all the
scenes he's in and he is clearly the
best thing about this movie I don't mean
that as a negative for the movie Elysium
you know usually in people who like the
best thing about the movie was this
thing and they mean it as a negative for
the movie not this case Elysium is great
it has a lot of great things in it and
in this pool of greatness there is one
great that is the greatest thing that's
this guy and it shows his crazy range as
an actor district 9 he was this
mild-mannered office guy just funny
because in district 9 he had a whole
character story arc so he ended the
movie is a different kind of guy that he
was in the beginning so that was
impressive right there then he was
howling mad Murdock in the a-team so it
was all crazy but like in a fun way not
like he is in Elysium where he's just a
really sick son of a and now you
have him in this movie and he's a
menacing psycho I think this guy could
play Barack Obama and I'd be like that
is Obama right there he is so yeah he's
pulling it off and I believe it's
actually him dude this guy's crazy I
can't praise him enough I'm just really
impressed by him and I'm really
surprised he's not in more things in the
end Elysium was a great sci-fi it had a
great hero a great villain a great
social message you can argue that it
gets a little preachy and whether you
agree with the message or you don't
agree with the message this is how I see
it at least we see a director pouring
some passion into his moving in 2013
let's face it it's just good to see you
direct to do that because so few have as
its establishing the world you're seeing
it gives a lot of information in a short
amount of time so it does seem like it's
rapid-fire it's been overloading at
times but it doesn't hold the entire
movie back if you're looking for a
really good sci-fi with a lot of really
good human elements this Elysium really
did it for me and my friends Elysium is
awesome tacular
all right so elysium have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more